hello everyone my name is Tamara
chambers
Walter Binet dziak I'm on the roof and
I'm ion away business scammers never
seen and others with friends so today we
are going to watch I had never even
heard of this film you brought it up to
all of us right yeah yeah it was like
the the worst movie ever made like
before the room before like troll 2 this
is like the original worst movie ever
because Emma wood was like the worst
filmmaker ever like before time so this
is like the old school tommy was so so
everyone in tampers never seen comments
is always like you guys do like older
films like you gotta cater to us like
old school people 1 out of 10 rating
what we think it's going to be like
truly what we think one being the best
one be who worse it's gotta be a 1 if
it'll worst movie ever it's got to be
one well I feel like I want to point it
like a 7 for fun yeah but like
entertainment like I'm expecting like a
it's like a 6 or 7 iron table yeah okay
you're sticking with one I want you to
quality I'm gonna say fine
middle-of-the-road
just because of I am I might like it
I've watched some pretty bad movies
recently that I've been highly
entertaining so hmm hell yeah okay one
two three
[Music]
all right it was a thing that we had to
watch maybe we should like compare it to
the room because that's like the modern
worst movie ever made like compared to
that what do you guys I think timewise I
think this took way longer to get
through the room the room is my
assistant Lee like fun to watch right
this was like the dialogue movie I'm
going to talk to you about a plot
what's this advise well the plan is a B
and C C a DD was so fun in certain
moments oh yeah like the terribleness is
hilarious who doesn't love watching
things be terrible in film fun super fun
and so sometimes there were some really
good like boom shots and boom Mike's in
the shot like Cemetery ground is so fun
to watch it with friends I think if I
was watching this alone I'm so much like
with people so much fun it was tough to
get through
[Laughter]
I love 100% the female wishes
I mean that's one of the weird things
come down and their master plan to
control earth is to raise people from
the dead and their vampire is taking
over the earth my god we should make
plan one from outer space also I really
wanted us to just show up for the
Stanford's ever seen and do be eyebrows
like this okay you know what I mean but
we did let's talk about specific
characters
oh those calm can we talk about how that
detective and his object work with the
gun pointing scratching big cop though
who you said used to be a wrestler for
Johnson
Yeah right look and when they gave him
like the no eyes yeah but he was the
other one his gaze
the aliens were the most on a lien like
feet Oh
at least okay the at least try with the
language and saying oh we don't speak
the same languages them so that's why we
haven't been able to understand the
messages they've been sending us we have
this language machines when they come in
make sure that language machine is on
otherwise we won't feel like they try
they were like when they come in turn
the 8th the language machine on but then
they leave the ship and everyone still
understand what the same I loved was
like should we maybe spend like the
extra $30 for another watch the right
colors any any time they colorize
something from black and white and never
really would I mean famous stuff like
America on 34th Street like old free
studio shorts or something and never
like translate the whole thing in itself
right that's the whole story that's
where Ed would tighten this is the only
reason I really know about this movie I
mean I kind of about it before but after
seeing a boy I'm like I gotta see play
another space cuz that would is kind of
about the making of it and it's the
early Tim Burton movie giant deaf it's
his best performance in my opinion with
a literally impossible waste that's
where a lot of decayed
that's why she didn't do anything I
think that made me uncomfortable with
the nails she was so much more respect
for that kind of stuff then like I mean
this is it's real there's one part where
they're all driving in the car and you
can float outside and all three of the
people in the car point their hands out
the window in unison one two three oh
yeah have you seen Ed Wood ed wood and
wood I wonder what the other eight plans
were you want to do cosplay a vampire
girl which good nickname because what
else what else is new but also like I
was saying previously
so yeah we feelin it you're going to be
surprised by how not you'll be very
bored it's not that NL Toyota scoreboard
but please go watch tubers you wonder
why Jeff says to shift your cigar-shaped
yeah thank you very much finally get
together with your friends to watch this
filled with people don't watch us alone
I don't drink a game of online thank you
so much for joining me everyone Thank
You Malcolm wherever you may be I will
see you all next week problems that
would so much you're watching I'll see
you guys next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you